you
so David thank you it's a real pleasure
to be hosting you at MSR today as part
of our distinguished AI lecture series
and I know you'll talk a little bit
later about some of your work on causal
modeling but what I want to do is you
know is take a step back and think about
how you got to where you are today so
right now you're a professor of
statistics computer science and in the
data science Institute at Columbia and
are clearly somebody who's very very
well-known in the area of probabilistic
topic modeling and and Bayesian machine
learning and so I want to understand how
you how you got there that you were an
undergraduate at Brown is that that's
right yeah in mathematics what what
caused you to go to Brown to study
mathematics yeah I was a undergrad at
Brown I love Brown and I I studied math
and CS it was a double major and also
first of all thanks for having me here
MSR has been a special place to me for
many years I was here as a grad student
so at Brown I majored in CS in math and
I had a professor there Leslie cabling
who she's since moved to MIT but she was
at Brown back then and she got me
interested in AI research she taught a
great class about AI and then invited me
to join her research lab and I wrote a
senior thesis with her and so she kind
of you know sparked my interest that's
great she was also Mike look Michael
Lippman's yeah he was my ta he was a
graduate student back when he was at
Bell Labs and so from there you went to
Berkeley to work with Mike Jordan again
how did you how did you pick him from
the the many options you probably had it
at the time and did you have any idea of
what you were going to focus on I didn't
so well it happened was after college I
moved to the Bay Area and I got a job at
SSRI research and I was writing Lisp
code just writing big software packages
and Lisp which I'm not sure we should be
doing but I but it was really fun and
what was the application
planning yeah so Karen Myers and was was
my boss and it was great and at some
point
Leslie emailed me and said hey you
should think about going to grad school
and so I applied to all a bunch of grad
schools and I wanted to stay in the Bay
Area and she said you should look up
Mike Jordan he's he's a good he's a good
adviser and this was a different time
where I could just email Mike Jordan you
know in 1999 and say hey I'm a
prospective PhD student you know can we
meet and he said sure and and so he sent
me a paper paper about variational
inference which has turned out to be
something I worked on a lot and we met
for 15 minutes and that was it and so
and I wanted to stay in the Bay Area and
I loved Berkeley from the minute I saw
it so I what's interesting about that is
really how many personal ties are
involved so leslie reached out to you
yeah she did I had no idea of it about
whether you had gone to Berkeley
explicitly to work with them or it seems
like a somewhat more less well-planned
and it's interesting in my career I've
also found that I make these real life
decisions based on an opportunity that
arises and so it's interesting to hear
that you've had some of those same
things yeah no it wasn't a big design
both of my parents went to Berkeley okay
anyway they were in graduate school
there so yeah it's you have it as I said
at the beginning an amazing influence in
statistics and in computer science and
in a variety of different application
areas from language modeling to some
recent applications in medical records
and understanding those you this is
evidenced by your citations which I
think are on the order of seventy
thousand citations over a little bit
more than 15 years one paper really
stands out in in that amazing
publication record and it's your paper
from 2004 with Andrew Inge and Mike
Jordan on Layton DeRusha lay allocation
that's that paper has been cited I just
looked it up last night 27,000 times so
that's
1,700 times a year about six almost
seven times per working day so this
paper is you know has had a tremendous
influence and I know that you know in it
you certainly reference some of the
early work that I had done on latent
semantic indexing some of the work that
Thomas Hoffman had done on probabilistic
latent semantic indexing or aspect
models and my recollection is that that
you really change that in a couple of
fundamental ways you first put it on
really strong theoretical foundations
and have generative models but also made
sure that documents and words were
interchangeable in in the
representations and so can you talk a
little bit about how you came up with
that that formulation how you decided to
look at some of the language modeling
aspects sure yeah I mean they you know
it's an honor to talk about it with you
it builds on your seminal work on latent
semantic analysis and that wasn't worth
it that wasn't generative but this is
but that was the story so so I went to
Berkeley and I did it was like the I
think it was the summer of 2000 or maybe
1999 I went on to a research internship
at NEC research was it Renny C research
yeah NEC research and I don't know if
it's around anymore
it was in Boston Oh in Boston okay I
might be getting the company wrong okay
but I definitely went to a research lab
in Boston and I worked with Pedro Moreno
it might have been Dec research that
think it's no longer there anyway so I
worked with Pedro Mourinho and what we
would he he was as he is in speech
recognition and he had this big data set
of radio transcripts they took radio
shows and they put them through a speech
recognizer and they had noisy
transcripts and he wanted to segment
them automatically and to make a long
story short we used a variant of the
aspect model of Thomas Hoffman's
method for finding topics in and at what
he called aspects and on text to segment
these noisy transcripts automatically
then I went back after the summer and my
officemate was answering and Andrew Inge
said let's have coffee and I said sure
so Andrew Inge and I went to brewed
awakening just a coffee shop next to the
cs department in berkeley and he said
what you work on over the summer
and I said well I worked on that
something related to the aspect model
and he said you know something has
always bothered me about the aspect
model and I'm not joking he took out a
napkin and he drew on the napkin the
simplex of how documents exhibit topics
the document topic simplex and pointed
out that the aspect model sets up a
parameter for each document of how it
exhibits each topic and that as the
dataset grows this is a these are
parameters that grow with the data and
that's usually a bad idea from a
statistical perspective it leads to
overfitting and things like that which
of course happen in that aspect model so
to be clear right in the history the
seminal work was yours to sort of
factorize the matrix of documents by
words right this was the this was the
act of inspiration Thomas Hoffman then
put it into a probabilistic framework
right and really christos papadimitriou
did - yes that was his work they put it
into a probabilistic framework that said
hey let's think about this factorization
in terms of documents generating words
and in Thomas Hoffman's there were
topics and there were documents and
documents each document was associated
with a parameter how much it exhibited
each topic and then what andrew inc
pointed out to me in brood awakening was
that you know it's bad statistical idea
to do that let's instead put a prior
over the over the topic proportions a
dear Ashley prior and let's see if we
can fit that model that made the whole
thing fully generative right when once
you put a prior on the topic proportions
if you put the hold the topics fixed
then you can now generate new documents
using the model that's the difference
between LSA pl
say an Lda and that was really where Lda
started that day then how long did it
take to get from that insight to thee
the early papers a lot of years I think
maybe one year or two years it was
anaerobes paper wasn't it so first it
was the nearest paper and there's a
story within a story there which is that
so then I said sure let's you know it
sounds fun let's work on it I was a
second year graduate student and that's
when I started learning about
variational inference so that's another
part of this picture is that is that so
here's this model and it's in it's hard
to calculate the distributions that you
need to use it and so I started learning
about variational inference which was
this method that Mike and his students
and then late 90s had started to work on
as a way to fit difficult to calculate
probability distributions his way to
approximate difficult to calculate
probability distributions and so it was
through working on Lda that I learned
about variational inference and then it
was through working on LD a that we
learned how to scale up variational
inference the whole thing took about two
years and I really liked it you know one
aspect of this that I really liked was
this was in 2000 I guess that we were
working on it the NURBS paper was from
2001 and I had a laptop and I could
store text data on my hard drive and I
just felt a jolt of excitement to be
able to kind of carry my laptop have
data on my laptop that I could analyze
and I mean I remember seeing the topics
emerge from those early analyses and it
was exciting it was magical to me I you
know maybe I was naive I was a student
and it was it was silly to feel magical
about those kinds of things and now of
course we know what was going on but I
you know there was a element of just raw
enthusiasm to why I like working on it
so at that time if I recall correctly
the the sorts of datasets you were
looking at were
things like some of the trek news wire
and data and maybe others and those were
on the order of 20 30 thousand yeah
short articles yeah that's right lesson
really twenty thousand was big five
thousand yeah and how many topics hidden
variables hundreds maybe a hundred but
when we started what did that take what
what how long did it take for you to
start you know with that amount of data
seeing result so days right so okay so
you weren't exactly watching the results
come out well I did have it the e/m
algorithm email me every time it
completed and I enjoyed that because in
the morning I woke up in my inbox was
filled with CEM iterations or more
usually my inbox was filled part way to
II M iterations and then it stopped as a
bug but ya know we parallelized it and
it was a it was a big effort to analyze
just five thousand documents now the way
we the way that we scaled it up back
then there really were some of the
innovations were from the computational
side okay but a big innovation was
algorithmic where we're at some point
you know I was scrutinizing the
variational updates the the updates to
the algorithm right and saw that there
was a clear way to make it faster
mathematically that let us scale from
five thousand to things like twenty
thousand okay scaling it to than a
hundred thousand and a million that
happened later on maybe ten years later
with stochastic optimization and so what
was he algorithmic insight that allowed
you to it was that a gradient that I was
zeroing out by taking gradient steps
could be zeroed out analytically it was
part of a more general story about
exponential families and variational
inference that was then told the
subsequent years it's really fun fun
story here talking about that you know
the size of the the data sets and the
compute power that that we had 15 years
ago versus now if you look at over the
last five to ten years the
the field of machine learning has been
really transformed by a lot of the deep
learning efforts starting originally in
speech and envision looking at some
lower level perceptual representations
and tasks but certainly over the last
three or four years looking at language
sort of discrete models with more
semantics and if you look at the the
latest GPT two models from open AI I
think they have eight billion words and
something on the order of a billion
parameters have you in you know in
working in this this space of modeling
of text and other discrete variables
taking any insights from empirically or
theoretically from just this the
tremendous you know data compute and
really representational richness that we
see in some of the current models is
that shaped your thinking or yeah it has
so maybe going back a little bit earlier
than three or four years ago
one paper came out the same year as the
LDA paper and JM LR is the word
embeddings paper the neural language
modeling paper by Benji Owen Oh Benji
yeah
and you know I I see the current trends
and innovations of language as really
building from that way of thinking about
representing vocabularies I say as
matters and something that we've been
doing recently is thinking carefully
about word embeddings now in some ways
you can I think they're doing different
things so this is where where I was
trying to get to and is that I think
embeddings and topic models are doing
different things topic models are
capturing heterogeneity in the documents
they're capturing that I can write a
document and it's about sports and
health or it's about business
and then somehow these two threads of
topics form different put different
statistical constraints on the words
that I use if it's about business that I
might use some business words and about
sports and some sports words and then
then if I take a document and I make it
about health and sports that I'm going
to use the same sports words and health
risks word embeddings are more focused
they're they're saying you know the
meaning of a word if a word is going to
occur with another word then it's
representation needs to play nicely with
that representation no matter what it is
and mathematically the difference is
between a mixture model and an
exponentiate adat product which is well
anyway which is where we got to when we
started studying Benjy owes paper this
was maybe five six years ago and and
something I'm interested in is combining
these two ideas I think there's
something really powerful about taking a
really high dimensional space like a
vocabulary and saying look I know that
there's two hundred thousand words in
this vocabulary but really there's a
hundred semantic dimensions in each word
is somehow represented in those
dimensions and then I get the things
like closeness of words that are similar
in in meaning I'm it's a very powerful
idea and it's one that is orthogonal or
complimentary to the idea of some topic
models which says that there are
heterogeneous topics expressed in
documents so so that's an area that
we're working on right now is how to
combine these two ideas another idea
that I think I really look forward to
hearing that that seems like a really
fundamental breakthrough in thinking
about representation and yeah they say
because you know topic models if you
expand the vocabulary I don't know if
you found this with LSA but at some
point we we you know I used to trim the
vocabulary when I fit a topic model for
computational I'm sure you did this
thing right you say okay I you know I'm
gonna select the top whatever five
thousand words by tf-idf but then
computation got better and we could
handle bigger vocabularies and we tried
to and we would expand the vocabulary
say in an Lda model and the model
wouldn't work and so what I thought we
were doing for computational reasons I
think we were also doing for statistical
reasons in that the law
long tail of the vocabulary the the very
rare words they can they can they can
misdirect the learning algorithm towards
decompositions into topics that don't
make sense and I think that combining
embeddings and topics together could
help solve that problem the other idea I
love in the recent wave of work on
language and deep learning is attention
yeah I think attachment is a very
powerful and interesting idea and you
know the same what we do in my group
we're not Microsoft and we don't have a
big cluster of computers and we can talk
about that later and huge you know huge
data sets but so but but we like to
glean you asked me what we can from the
beaver from these recent innovations
what we like to glean from them are
mathematical ideas that could be used or
made for more formal perhaps generalized
right and so I think attention is one of
those ideas that that that has a lot of
potential where the idea being that the
features that I use to predict some kind
of outcome which ones are relevant right
could depend on the whole feature set as
well
that's the way I think of attention I
think it's a really beautiful
interesting idea that's not really
looked at much in statistics and in
machine learning but via attention we
can start thinking about that in more
broad areas yeah that sounds really fun
I'd like the notion of trying to make
some structure in some ways with with
these embeddings you did some of your
early work that I really liked
did some of this you brought various
kinds of structure to topic models yeah
you did some work on correlated topic
models on hierarchical topic models and
my favorite in that family of extensions
of topic models was the one where you
looked at dynamic topic models bringing
a notion of time yeah can you comment on
sort of what and I know you've done
stuff that's related to that recently
again looking at dynamic embeddings yeah
can you talk a little bit about time and
how it was how you thought about it in
and sure how you think about it a decade
later yeah so I I'm glad you brought up
that work i i'm also very continue to be
excited i just went a test of travel
wartime serious it did it was offensive
time award i i'm excited about the idea
of time series of documents especially
the kind that we look at when we analyze
scientific literature that change over
hundreds of years right and so yeah so
that you know the story behind that work
is that I was a postdoc at Carnegie
Mellon with John Lafferty and John I
went to that postdoc partly so that I
could drive to Michigan to see my wife
okay because John Lafferty is very
inspiring Perseus and when I when I met
him when I was interviewing for the
postdoc he said you know what would be
fun to work on I made a deal with JSTOR
JSTOR this online archive of academic
papers I made a deal with JSTOR and
they're gonna hand me all the OCR from
their journals and their journals go
back hundreds of years and you know we
should play with this what what could we
do with it and so you know we got the
data and we got in particular science
magazine from for a hundred years from
like 1880 to the year 2000 out of 20
years and you know the assumption the
tacit assumption of Lda of that the
documents are basically exchangeable
that it doesn't matter which one came
first in which one him last that
assumption flies out the window right we
all agree that topics the way you
described neuroscience in 1900 is
different from the way you describe
neuroscience in 1990 but they are
somehow the same topic so it was it was
motivated by that data set that we
wanted to look at how documents change
over time but what did many things could
change over time right so one is really
the semantics of the world the topics
are embedded dimensions that you have
and another is a vocabulary and
breakthroughs in each one of those which
of those do you think was was happening
is it sort of the fundamentals of
semantics that are changing or is it the
richness in different parts of that that
space well in the science case I think
it was the fields were changing right
these you know another side of this is
that why do we want to use topic models
often it's so that we can interpret
what's going on in the dataset learn
something about that data and so if you
are if your idea is that the topics are
representing real fields in the world
then and you want to be able to connect
say an article about neuroscience in
1882 an article about neuroscience in
1990 then you have to address that they
don't use the same vocabularies to talk
about the same field
sure so I think it is the vocabulary
that's changing but that's really kind
of a proxy for the knowledge changing
right
what were some of the fun insights that
you took either from that dataset or
more foundational insights about
modeling techniques for data that's
certainly not uniform over yeah every
time and well I mean there are some fun
things that we found well one thing it
was a very distracting project because I
mentioned that I felt a lot of passion
in grad school just analyzing text date
it was fun and this data set is
incredibly fun right yeah of course
historical science articles and you know
I remember finding one about ice cream
where you know an old article about a
scientist who is figuring out whether or
not ice cream is poisonous or something
like that anyway it's a lot of hilarious
and a lot of days gone to reading
hundred-year-old science articles you
spent your time at worse ways yeah
what's true so the one when you know one
result I remember from that work is this
is that you know again why we fit a
topic models cuz we want to somehow
represent the fields of the document is
talking about and and when documents pan
hundreds of years those fields changing
you need to acknowledge that if you want
to make the connections so we built a
way to find similar articles based on
topic so you you have to do this with
LSA to write you would use the per
document representation that LSA
provides for you to find other similar
article
now what's cool about topics over topics
over time dynamic topics is that when
you do that the the topic 58 year 1880
is different from the perspective of the
vocabulary from topic 50 in Wright 1980
but they are connected by smoothly
changing words throughout those hundred
years and that lets us connect then a
document that's that by tf-idf would
have nothing in common right right you
writing about neuroscience in 1980 has
nothing in common with me writing about
neuroscience in 1880 but they are
connected via the topics so the the
result that I remember was that you know
in whatever year was 1920 I think it was
there was a kind of crude science
article about somebody dissecting an
orangutan brain and so they basically I
think in the article might even been
called on the brain of the array or
something like that but anyway they so
in that article they kind of take an
orangutan bonk it on its head open up
the brain draw what they saw send it to
science and if you look at the whole
corpus a hundred thousand articles for
one hundred and fifty thousand articles
the article closest to that was from
1980 which was basically a modern
version of the same thing with all this
kind of fancy imaging and other
neuroscience methods so it struck me
because these are two articles that
again from the tf-idf perspective from
term frequencies are completely
independent of each other and more or
less but they really the dynamic topic
model captured this this I think of it
as a subtle connection that these the
same field changed over a hundred years
but within that field these two articles
are describing the same
there was a technical aspect to that
work - which was that that was the first
time we really started analyzing
document sizes of the order of hundreds
of thousands and with the time series it
was and it was it was particularly
complicated because the time series
destroyed a lot of the nice
computational aspects of LD a the simple
LD a paper from 2003 so in the context
of that paper that was the first time I
really dealt with not what I call non
conjugate models models that don't enjoy
the same mathematical properties that
ld8 enjoy and the 150,000 articles was
another challenge so I I see that work
as what kind of bringing my research
into that the it's next phase which was
around non conjugate models and larger
datasets but time is a particularly
interesting and time to talk a little
bit maybe at an intuitive level about
how you evolve the the topic model over
time or how you sure so there were a few
works about topics over time and the
first one the one with John in 2006 that
one basically said look there are two
say hundred topics and each one instead
of just being a distribution over words
which is what topics are usually is now
a sequence of distributions over words
and moreover there is a smoothness to it
so that the probability of the word
brain in 1880 is going to be close to
the probability of the word brain in
1881 it's gonna be close to the
probability of the word brain in 1882
and so on and that's it so we assume
that they smoothly change over time and
then you condition on the documents and
you and you learn these topics that go
from you know a kind of crude way of
talking about the brain in 1880 to a
more refined way of talk about the
in 1900 run it backwards startled an
Atari is a great idea yeah I mean it did
also do some funny things it's our
perspective on the world right we live
in a world where the topics of the
discuss the things we take for granted
shape how we interpret older run it
backwards
so like one funny thing that happened
with that well I remember too is the
word laser lasers were invented in 1960
yeah but I mentioned that it that you
know that the probability has changed
smooth right and so in 1960 people
started talking about lasers but because
the model required that the that the
word probabilities change smoothly what
it did to account for how much people
talked about lasers in 1960 is that it
gave later higher and higher probability
even before it was invented so I you
know we called that the laser problem we
didn't solve it was like looking into
the future yeah so you know the kind of
the public relations way of saying it is
oh look at this model it's so
intelligent it's predicting them lasers
but really what's happening is that the
linear dynamic system that we imposed on
the model and it was another lesson for
us around kind of you know modeling
assumptions and data together interact
and and when we're building models deep
learning models too we'd have to think
about that yeah right how much of what
we're getting out of the model is coming
out of the assumptions we're making and
how much of it is coming even the
objective function so it's been really
fun to hear about the evolution of your
thinking about topic models
representation of text and now thinking
about interesting ways to combine that
with you know some of the embedding work
one of the switch gears a little bit and
talk about your work in causal inference
here and what you're going to talk about
later today I guess is some of that
thinking thinking about how to deal with
causal reasoning in the case where we we
don't have from observational data in
the case where we don't have a carefully
controlled experiment and as I
understand it your work tries to reduce
some of the pretty stringent assumptions
that had been present in earlier
models about the need to observe all the
confounding examples can can you talk to
you know a little bit about that and how
you got interested in the topic and how
you're moving forward in that space
sure so I about five years ago I moved
from Princeton to Columbia right and I I
don't know if it was a causal effect but
when I got to Columbia I become
interested in causal inference okay I
had been interested in it before and I'm
reading about it and and and trying to
learn about it and then when I got to
Columbia I don't know it was a it was a
change so I thought okay you know and so
I sat down with my lab and and we
started reading everything we could find
about causal inference and there's
there's many really good books out there
about causal inferences lots of
different perspectives on causal
inference so there's a good book by in
men's and Reuben yeah it's a good book
by pearl a good book by her nan and
Robbins there's all this lots of work on
causal effects and my motivation was you
know that for years we've been working
on finding structure in large data sets
and analyzing large data sets with
machine learning and it's all been it's
all for explanation and observation um
when we look at topics they seem like
they are real things right this was part
of our history
my labs history but we all knew that you
know that they were artifacts of this
data set that had happened to fall in
our lap so how can we you know the
question I wanted to ask was how can we
use these tools these machine learning
tools that we've we the community have
spent decades developing to really say
something about how the world works and
it feels silly you know the causal
inference theory is quite conservative
but it felt silly it felt unintuitive to
say I can observe you know millions and
millions and millions of electronic
health records but without a controlled
trial I can't tell you that
we'll help your headache alright this
was the this was kind of my motivation
and it's you know it's uh it's a cartoon
of course causal inference miles racial
data has been around a long time but
this was the this was by domestication
like I want to be able to do what we do
with millions of data points but do it
in the service of really understanding
something about the world ok so that's
how we got into it and we started
reading all kinds of books about it and
then I taught a couple of classes about
it and you know it's kind of no better
way to learn than to sign up to teach a
class about it and it was through those
classes that we started reading about
some stuff in the genetics literature
that seemed to point towards a way to
find unobserved confounders with latent
variable models like LD and I say and
and so you know it wasn't said
explicitly but it was hinted at in the
literature and then with one of you know
my great student machine Wang she really
she and I formalized what that meant and
and I think it's a interesting result
I'll talk about it this afternoon the
punchline of it for for you know to the
degree that this conversations about
like my research over the course of the
years is that all these models that we
were building these topic models and
other lay invariable models that we were
building over the years we the whole
Bayesian machine learning community they
all come into play in this work to help
to find unobserved confounding so it was
kind of nice because it gave us a
purpose for doing all this unsupervised
learning and pattern finding so can you
give a hint about how that works are you
identifying structure maybe Co linearity
or something about variables or is that
sort of the let me give more detail so
so the idea is it's we call it multiple
causal inference first of all and the
idea is that you know in a typical
causal inference problem you might want
to know does
they'll help a headache right in a
multiple causal inference problem you
have many many type possible causes and
an outcome and you want to know you know
what is the causal effect of each of
these causes now the example we use in
our paper is actors and movie revenue
that's the example I use in my talk to
so I have you know a data set of who was
in what movie and how much money the
movie made and I want to know how
valuable each actor is now the problem
with all causal inference is confounding
what confounding means is that there
might be variables lurking in the
background that affect what who I put in
the movie or whether or not I take Advil
and affect the outcome by how much money
the movie makes or whether the advil
helps so within the case of advil I know
that advil helps me so I take Advil and
then that helps my headache now that
confounds a estimate of how good advil
is because if I just count up the number
of people for whom advil helps I I'm
gonna get an overestimate of its of its
efficacy for the movie example the
example I like to give is James Bond
movies right if I'm gonna make a James
Bond movie that tells me who I'm gonna
cast and it also tells me that the
movies gonna make a lot of money I'm
gonna cast James Bond and I'm gonna cast
the other people that recur James Bond
movies and the James Bond movies gonna
make a lot of money so the idea behind
the paper is this when you have multiple
causes like you have many actors there's
correlation the the hidden confounders
like James Bond is okay they induce
correlation among who's in the movie
right so that's just Sean Connery and
Miss Moneypenny and M and Q they're all
correlated in terms of appearing in the
movie and you can imagine a mixture
model or a factor model an LSA model
these can capture this correlation and
the theory says the paper the
theoretical ask part of that paper the
paper provides an algorithm but also a
theory the theory says that that
variable that hidden variable that you
infer using the methods of probabilistic
machine learning that captures a certain
class of unobserved confounders so you
can analyze the data just of who's in
what movie and then use
the hidden variable that you infer in
that analysis to correct for some of the
confounding without having to go and
measure the confounding explicitly so it
is so the idea to build on what you said
is that that collinearity the dependence
structure between the causes is in
direct evidence for hidden confounding
and we can use machine learning to
extract that information without having
to explicitly understand what it is love
to look forward to here you are about it
the hardest a blackboard we don't have a
blackboard we have a nice wall behind us
that we shouldn't mess up we have my pen
or chart let me ask you one last
question first of all it's been really
fun listening to the many different
people and perspectives that have
influenced your your research I for
example didn't know about the you know
and rue-ing's influence or John
Lafferty's and and now more recently
when you move to to Columbia just a
different set of people a different set
of problems and you historically have
always been able to smoothly go in and
out of different communities so some of
your early work was in CGI are you know
some in you know nur ups and I CML you
also have done work that has more of a
cognitive science flavors so working
with Griffiths and Josh Tenenbaum and
I'd love that that breadth of
perspectives you have a sense of how you
pull this off and what you get from each
of those different disciplines I well
thanks for saying that I pull it off
well it's hard to influence many
different fields right yeah and you seem
to you know have an ability to take
ideas from one and bring them to another
and it it's been a real formula for
success I think I think in your work and
and others well yeah the way I like to
work is you know I'm interested in lots
of things so I need people from
different areas
and become interested in what they work
on recently I've been working with Susan
atheon
around a metric methods for example and
on one hand and on the other hand or not
on the other hand and simultaneously I'm
interested in developing new machine
learning methods and new ways to extract
value from data think about machine
learning that way and you know I don't
want to build machine learning methods
in a vacuum right we could you know if
you think about what we could do with
machine learning that we could do
anything but you want to do something
that's useful to somebody and so for me
the way that I and that's that's one
that's one reason to to reach out to
other communities to find out what kinds
of problems they are working on and the
other reason is that you know to
understand the limitations of machine
learning we need to use it to try to
solve new kinds of problems right that's
gonna stress test yeah and so you know
those are that's where my motivation
comes from so like right now for example
I'm like I said I've been working with
Susan Athey and econometrician a great
one and I've also started working with
some astrophysicists and some people
that work on the microbiome who have
fascinating problems they're they're
different from the kinds of problems
that we solved traditionally and machine
learning and they're stretching what you
know what we need to be able to do right
I think that frankly I think the story
of probabilistic machine learning
Bayesian machine writing and how
approximate inference you know back when
we were doing LD a we had to have
certain conjugate forms of all of
relationships between the hidden
variables and the observations to be
able to even though the whole thing
wasn't conjugate we had to have
conjugacy within each pair to be able to
do variational inference through working
with real scientists that motivated
getting out of that I say yeah you know
removing that limitation and moving to
non conjugate models and work on like
probabilistic programming and black box
variational inference that's stemmed
from this need for working with non
conjugates
and non conjugate also is where deep
learning comes in deep generative models
right sometimes be models but anyway so
yeah thanks for saying I pull it off but
in an amazing anyway and and what's
interesting is I guess you hinted at it
in your answer it's not just talking to
people with different technical
backgrounds with that's right the
statistics and computer science and
maybe cognitive science but really
blending theory and practice and so it
sounds in your own work that you get
hooked on a problem you know and then
given the broad perspective do you bring
try to figure out how to yeah and it's
tricky you know one aspect of it is you
do want to make sure that you're working
on a problem that is going to push
machine learning in a new direction
right right so a lot sometimes I talk
with scientists and the answer is the
hmm no they want to hear hmm okay
they're happy to learn about it solves a
problem but then that what they want is
they say okay great so can you fit the
hmm and I think what we can but it's not
really you know that's not really um
though that's really changed so one
thing I've also noticed is that in my
class on probabilistic machine learning
I used to get computer science students
and statistics students now I get
students from every department and
they're just saying you know they are
students of many fields are now becoming
versed and technical and programming and
and doing machine learning which is
great for our field and do you see that
in the date of Science Institute that
that I mean part of the reason for that
I guess was that it did bring different
application areas different problem
areas together with the hopes of
creating the same theoretical
foundations and underpinnings yeah I
mean I use I use applied machine
learning and data science
interchangeably although maybe I should
be more nuanced so let me just ask one
one final question
oh and that is what what advice do you
have for students who are interested in
getting into
applied machine learning data science
and computer science more generally what
what's sort of backgrounds and
perspectives do you look for for example
in students that you take into your
leather hmm that's a good question so
well there those are two questions okay
whichever both both so the background
that I look for in students and postdocs
in my group you know I'm looking for
students who will want will be
interested in this kind of model that I
just described we were gonna reach out
across disciplines we're gonna look for
somebody who has an apply problem that
we're interested in and try to make
progress on a regular problem with real
data set and that might involve
theoretical work and applied work I'm
looking for students then who you know
our comfortable programming and working
on real-world problems and also students
who are comfortable with mathematics and
statistics to be clear I'm also looking
for students who are who are willing to
find something that they're interested
in so and this goes along with my advice
for somebody who wants again festiveness
who wants to get into applied machine
learning research I think it's important
and if it's it's how it's it's what got
me excited back in Berkeley to be doing
something you're interested in and to be
clear with my students I don't even need
to be that interested in what they're
working on and I should be interested in
the technical aspects of it the machine
learning aspects tonight but the domain
I want it to be a domain that gets you
ahead in the morning like if like text
was for me when I was in graduate school
and because I think that that's really
important graduate school is you know is
can be difficult from the motivation
perspective sometimes and you need to
you know having something that that
keeps you excited is it's really
important to getting through the ups and
downs of graduate school which is
ultimately really worthwhile but can be
difficult
so you know my advice is to find
something you like not to worry about
trends and fads in the field because
you'll do your best work if you're
working on something that you'd like to
work on both from the technical
perspective the methodological
perspective and from the which
application you choose if you see that
he trends over the last the 15 years and
in which you've been a professor and the
kinds of things that attracts students
to thinking about applications of
machine learning or AI think there's a
lot of work I've seen in the last few
years about AI for social good response
so do you see some of that trend or is
it really very by person rather than by
time I think it varies by person
although I I have noticed that I don't
know if it's a trend or if it's just my
group right now there's a lot of
interest in the social aspect right of
machine learning and also in the
computational social sciences I think it
is great also a great area for like
quantitative political science and
sociology these are great areas for
machine learning where we can have a big
impact and where it's not yet as widely
used great David thank you so much for
first of all visiting Microsoft spending
the time to do this really maybe a
little bit about you know what drives
David to the amazing influence that he's
had in the community I've learned a lot
actually about some of the inspiration
for your work and and the guiding
principles that you use to drive your
own interest in in the field so thanks
for taking the time to talk to us